it's great to be joined once again today
by bill scher who is contributing editor
to Politico magazine host of the new
books in politics podcast part of the
new books Network and also I guess sort
of bill like increasingly a recipient of
ire from so-called actual progressives
right like is that fair to say at this
point well that comes down to how you're
defining the word progressive I
definitely have been in the wake of the
midterms noting that certain folks on
the Left who argued that you needed a
robust economic populism you if not
outright democratic socialism you needed
that to flip red turf in this midterm
I've been noting that that did not bear
out in this election and there are some
one left that are happy with my analysis
but I think the the facts of the facts
well let's get into one of those
analyses so to speak which is about the
what I guess at this point we can't
really say that the effort to the extent
that it exists to select someone other
than Nancy Pelosi as Speaker of the
House when Democrats take over control
in January I don't think we can say it
has failed yet because it just hasn't
happened one way or the other but
needless to say it doesn't seem as
though the effort is really coalescing
into something that has a very specific
person attached to it or a path to sort
of someone other than Nancy Pelosi being
Speaker for Democrats do we do we sort
of agree on the facts there oh yeah I
think the the Pelosi the anti Pelosi
revolt is is sputtering if not
completely dead at this point and that's
probably because your Pelosi did have
critics on her left she is democratic
establishment she controlled the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee which interfered in a lot of
primaries and to try to get people who
they considered more electable and
pushing aside folks they thought were
too left for certain districts and
there's a lot of grinding of teeth on
the left about things like that Plus
Pelosi was involved with the Welsh Wall
Street bailout she's a big fundraiser
something she's too close to
corporations but that faction of Pelosi
critics is not part of the the
leadership of the revolt which is
congressman Seth Moulton in Northeast
Massachusetts and his band of roughly
1415 people are more on the right edge
of the caucus and one of the mistakes I
think Moulton may and I think it was a
tough slog no matter how well he
executed it was that he couldn't bring
together the left and the right critics
of Pelosi to say look there we have a
broad spectrum of opposition here and
that's why you can't unify the caucus
instead the the reality is Pelosi is
unifying the caucus Pelosi has not not
only locked down the left but a good
part of the right edge of the caucus as
well which is leaving the Moulton folks
out on the cold yeah I mean I I am more
inspired by motivated by I guess you
would say the anti Pelosi arguments that
focus on the establishment the corporate
connections the role sort of within what
is increasingly in my view kind of like
an antiquated left that is not
particularly interested in some of the
new ideas that are being brought forward
not that I agree with every single one
of those ideas but that's the critique
of Pelosi that that that is more
relevant to me where I thought that the
movement and I'm curious whether you
agree got sort of off the rails was more
I don't want to just blanket use the
term the identity politics line but the
idea of pointing to we should really
have someone who checks different
identity boxes and that to me is a less
compelling argument for a lot of reasons
including that Seth Moulton seemed to
want Marcia fudge to be Speaker of the
House who yes she is not a white woman
but she's still part of the same sort of
Pelosi generation and maybe even had
some of the same deficits that you could
identify with Pelosi I don't know I mean
I said a lot of stuff there but what
what's your sense of these two that the
sort of critique that is more relevant
to me and the less relevant one well I I
put a little bit
then you did I agree with you that the
molten forces didn't have a much of a
substantive issues based critique of
Pelosi okay
there this was like a couple years now
and for folks virtually I did write
about this for Politico a couple of
pieces one that was titled forget Pelosi
challenged Hoyer who's the number two in
the Democratic leadership and a second
one the pathetic Pelosi push which is
sort of the post mortem are pre post
more if if you will
Moulton's argument has long been that we
need a new generation of leadership and
undergirding that that Pelosi is bad
political baggage we we can't win the
house with Pelosi at the front this was
articulated over the course of 2017 and
part of 2018 and it wasn't about how she
did the job it wasn't about the issue
she prioritized it was that she was a
bad look
and once Democrats picked up a net of
forty seats in the house the political
argument was neutralized yet the
multiples still wanted to make this new
generation argument and a new generation
arguing if it's not connected to
something substantive and issues based
then it's just ageism why you're you are
old and even though you're doing a good
job you should move aside for somebody
young if that's it that's not a very
compelling argument so what Moulton did
was he tried to add an identity politics
argument to it which is we need a more
diverse set of faces in the party well
if that's the argument why are you
strictly focusing on the woman at the
top of the leadership structure and
ignoring the number two guys Teddy Hoyer
who's the only white male when there's a
ruling troika of the Democratic House
leadership its Pelosi Hoyer and Jim
Clyburn who's a net who's
african-american male so you know the
three together are a diverse group just
except for age and if you want to say
look we want to get some age in there
well that's a fine argument but just
swapping out one woman for another
even though the woman that molten one
was african-american that and ignoring
the white male at first I think that
didn't fly if he had started the day
after the election with a slate of
challengers against all three that were
diverse in every respect not just race
not just gender but also age and
ideology it might have been a different
story but instead he hung it on Pelosi
at first he elevated fudge fudge
abandons him besides with Pelosi so he
loses that talking point and and and and
he also tried to argue that well if we
had a different leadership we'd have
more diversity in the committee
chairmanships which also ignore the fact
that ten of the twenty-one incoming
committee chairs are going to be
non-white males and they're gonna be old
in most cases often over seventy but if
you're going to abolish the seniority
system you might set back those
diversity efforts people who are not
white males who had climbed up the rugs
you're going to leave them out in the
cold so I mean Danny Pollock's for
Moulton was was a desperate stretch
because his initial arguments weren't
taking off well there's I think
underlying a lot of this there is this
split between idealism and pragmatism
that exists and this is something I mean
I think the left struggles with it in
some cases I I admit that in some
instances I also struggle with it and an
example of this is the article you wrote
this morning which talks about that the
green New Deal proposed by Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez and others and supported
by others versus this almost unknown to
many people bipartisan bill called the
energy innovation and carbon dividend
Act and what you point out and I know
there will be people in my audience who
will be angry at both of us are talking
about this you point out that the green
new deal on whatever its merits are
which we could talk about and I like the
idea with the Republican Senate and
Donald Trump in the White House is just
not going to pass and thus for the next
two years when Democrats will control
the house but not the Senate and not the
White House
they're not a pragmatic benefit to
figuring out well what can we actually
achieve to better be positioned in 20 20
or 20 21 it which is effectively what it
would be is this an idealism pragmatism
split or is it something else oh it's
it's definitely that and keep in mind
this shows that even though there is an
idealist pragmatist divided between
Pelosi and more progressive members of
the caucus it's not stopping closely
from becoming Speaker the idealist have
made a decision that it wasn't it was
gonna be more beneficial to try to work
with Pelosi on this score and pressure
the Democratic establishment to put more
idealistic legislation on the floor then
by fighting a futile battle with a bunch
of relatively conservative Democrats as
as their wing men who don't agree with
them on their idealistic goals so so
Pelosi is almost sure to be speaker but
she is going to be pressured by okays or
Cortes and others who don't like the
fact that the Congressional Progressive
Caucus up into this point has not been
very calm 'print a tional they want to
force issues on the floor they want
things like green new deal and maybe I
don't want to put words in their mouth
mean I'm assuming single-payer maybe
other things on immigration that the
more moderate members of their caucus of
which there are now many more after the
midterms the people that won in Trump
districts did not run on a single-payer
abolish eyes platform they ran on being
bipartisan problem solvers
so they're gonna say to Pelosi hey don't
make me vote on the whole progressive
wish lists because that's gonna split my
base where I'm from in South Carolina
one or Oklahoma five or I owe a three so
that's gonna be very difficult for
Pelosi to navigate and to get back to
the specific issue on climate which is
shaping up to be the number one priority
the new faction of populist progressives
just saying green new deal as a slogan
is inoffensive done with anybody who
cares about the environment sure I don't
cares with the climate but the specific
ask here is to create a new committee
with a charge of producing a specific
kind of climate proposal it's not to
have a broader bit what should the
policy be it said the policy should be a
plan to zero out all fossil fuels in a
ten year span which is a very rapid time
frame and do it with massive investment
in other words spend a lot of money and
nobody who won in the redder parts of
America on the Democratic side ran on
being big spenders so that's why you're
not seeing a rush to sponsor or kZO
Cortez's proposal here if she has about
17 sponsors right now and at the same
time also so she had a rally last week
on this subject also last week you have
this new bill for a bipartisan carbon
tax and this is being proposed by John
Delaney who's an outgoing congressman
but is running for president a very
wealthy guy bankrolling is what efforts
me a lot time in Iowa to Republicans who
are gonna be in the next Congress Ryan
Fitzpatrick who won in Pennsylvania one
whether one of the only Republicans in a
Clint in one district to win this past
November as well as these names escape
me I wants a Rooney
I believe he's up in on Michigan I'm
more conserved istrict there now you
could say to Republicans that's pathetic
why would you argue that this has a
better chance of becoming a law than the
green you deal they both have to get the
Republican Senate they both have to be
signed by President Trump that's not
going to happen that's correct
nothing is going to happen on the
climate front in the next two years the
question is how do Democrats want to
position themselves and and set the
stage for a climate legislation if they
have a good election year in 2020 and
having an R
equipment between different approaches
is perfectly fine as far as I'm
concerned I'm not saying the carbon tax
is has a glide path to success in the
green New Deal doesn't but it doesn't
make sense to me to have a committee
that blocks out other possible
approaches and I find a totally bizarre
that you have a carbon tax two years ago
was considered the highest of
progressive goals Bernie Sanders tried
to drive a wedge between himself a
Hillary Clinton by saying I'm for a
carbon tax and she's not you now have a
bill that has a carbon tax and the left
is ignoring it so why is that it's
because it's a revenue neutral carbon
tax it does not raise revenue to fund
something like a green new deal it
instead whatever money they get from the
carbon tax they return it to the
American people and that divide you saw
the last couple years in Washington
State they've had two different ballot
initiatives there one that was a revenue
neutral carbon tax it lost there was
revenue raising carbon tax this year it
lost it divided the left in the center
and it still divided left and center
today both articles that we've been
talking about that bill wrote one on
political one on RealClearPolitics we're
linking to both of them we've been
speaking to Bill share a contributing
editor to Politico bill thank you as
always my pleasure